[music]
>> Okay, hello everybody.
I'm going [clears throat] to show you
today how to run Gemma 4 on iPhone with
MLX. So, first let's introduce myself.
I'm Adria. You can find my Twitter if
you want to learn more about all on
device things. I'm a developer of
Locally AI, so maybe you have already
seen
the the app. So, Locally AI is a chatbot
that allow you to run on device models
on your iPhone with MLX. So, I will just
go through what is MLX in a in a few few
seconds.
Basically,
as I said, it's it's a chatbot. It's
fully native. You can also chat with
Apple Foundation with it. And
and many models like that are compatible
with MLX. And one of those models is
Gemma 4. So, basically, [clears throat]
Gemma 4 by Google in mind have a lot of
model and some of them like can run on
iPhone like the smaller ones and they
are pretty great.
Maybe you have seen on on Twitter one of
the post I've made that I should I demo
it running in the app on iPhone. It's
really fast. It runs really well on MLX.
And behind the app, so
it's using [clears throat] MLX. MLX is a
framework made by Apple that is
optimized for Apple Silicon. So, mainly
mainly the
the chip [clears throat] in iPhone, but
also the chips on the on the Mac. The
the app Locally is available on iPad. It
works also very well on this device and
Mac OS. And everything is is built to be
as optimized as possible on on this
devices.
So, if you want if you want to run on
iPhone
a language model, so Gemma works well,
but you have a lot of model that you can
run also. The Quen model and
and the small LM model from Hugging
Face. The place you you will want to go
is GitHub and go to the repo MLX Swift
LM. I won't go into detail how you
implement the repo. It's I think I will
let your agent in a implement that for
you, but it's one repo that you need to
install if you're developing an iOS or
Mac OS or iPad OS app. And you can use
you can use that to simply download the
model and then run it. The API is very
straightforward, very simple to to
implement. In less than 10 minutes, you
can have an iOS app with a model that is
running
on your on your device. That's very
simple to do. As as mentioned, MLX So,
this is MLX Swift LM, but if you're more
into Python apps or Mac OS app, you can
also run MLX VLM from from Prince. Maybe
you have seen him that he's doing on
device for audio with MLX audio and
visual model with MLX VLM and also MLX
video to to run
to run
image image generation model or image or
video generation model. MLX it's the
ecosystem is getting bigger
it's getting bigger it's it's really
great right now. You can do pretty much
everything like omni models. As I say,
text to speech speech speech to speech.
There's a lot of thing that you can do
with um
with a model. And basically, let's say
you integrate the you integrate
this model. You can't just run any model
on it. Like you need to you need to get
some model and there's a good place to
get the model is Hugging Face. I'm
pretty sure everybody heard uh of
Hugging Face. And on Hugging Face, you
will want to look for MLX community.
This is where like all of the the weight
of the model, the quantized weight, the
full size will be uploaded.
So, you will just be able to go to this
community look for the models. I think
right now there's almost 4,000 or 5,000
model uploaded. So, the community is
really active on it. When a model is is
released by a by a lab you will directly
have it almost 30 minutes after release
quantized in 4-bit, 6-bit
and everything that you can you can
imagine. Here you have like an example
for Gemma 4 8-bit, which is the one I I
run on um on iPhone. There's like a lot
of variant of it for from BF16 and make
MXFP4 [clears throat]
like 5-bit, 6-bit
there's everything. So,
so you download MLX Swift LM, install it
with your agent or anything. Then you go
to MLX community and you just choose the
model you want to run and then with ID
you can just pass it to the framework
and it will directly it will be
integrated with Hugging Face to download
the model with MLX Swift LM directly.
So, you just need to grab the ID and and
pass it to to the framework.
Usually, when you're running the the
model on
on iPhone, what you want to what you
want to do is quantize select selecting
some quantized quantized version of the
model because the full size will be way
too large. What I recommend is going is
trying depending on the size between
3-bit and and 8-bit. Usually, between
4-bit and 8-bit. Usually, under like
4-bit it's getting it's starting to get
a lot of impact on the output. And
and the model are not that great
usually. 4-bit is the lower I would go.
And 8-bit is the higher I would go if
you're using really small models. And in
my app for example, I have like some
bigger model like Gemma 4, but I also
have some liquid model where that is 300
350 parameters and this it can run in
shortcuts. So, you can do a lot of kind
of automation because the model are
really fast and really efficient at that
at that size to do some text processing
and things like this.
And on the on the latest iPhone like if
you take Gemma 4 8-bit quantized in
4-bit it's extremely fast. Like it can
run easily at 40 token 40 token
per second. I will just do an update in
the slide because I remove
I remove a slide where there's the
video, but maybe I can add it back
because I have a little bit more time.
I just like this. So, just to show you
in demo what's what the 40 token per
second means.
And that's running live offline.
And as you can see, it's like really
fast. Like 40 token per second is more
than acceptable for a lot of use cases.
This is of course streaming. You can
also like not do streaming and do a UI
that just will wait for for 4 seconds.
And here the output is quite long. So,
it's generating a lot of tokens. On
device with MLX, it's working. It's
here. Like it's really not easy and
really not hard to to integrate.
As I said, if you go to the to the repo
MLX Swift LM very it's a breeze to to
install.
On top of that, as I said like again,
latest iPhones really great, but it
works also with older iPhone. Like you
will not get 40 token per second, which
is quite fast, but even if you get 20
tokens per second, that's already great
and useful for a lot of
for a lot of application a lot of use
cases that you would want to do with
with your
with your with your app. You can go to
and scan this QR code if you want to try
it by yourself. If you want to have a if
you have an iPhone, the app is on the
App Store. It's free to use.
Only thing is that you will have to
download the model that's usually around
1 gigabytes
or 3 gigabytes. Really depend on the on
which model, but that's the biggest
barrier right now. It's the size of the
model, but this also is getting better.
Model are getting smaller or getting
smarter and they're also the iPhone is
getting better. So, next and second the
next next iPhone everything will just is
reaching really great usability from
what I can see. And also on top of that
like maybe you have heard the news
yesterday. Locally have been acquired by
LM Studio. If you don't know
LM LM Studio
>> [clears throat]
>> it's basically
a kind of a AI studio for all your local
models. So, you can download the the
model with any model with LM Studio
directly from Hugging Face. You can run
them and you can open a server. You can
run them with Llama CPP, but also MLX.
So, you can really compare the different
engine how they
how they work. You can
as I said, you can open a
a server locally and connect your app
to this to this hosted server with
various
various response response type. For
example, open open API response type or
>> [clears throat]
>> or
or Anthropic response type for streaming
anything and you can just get any model
running really easily with that.
So, and I want to thank you. That was a
very short introduction how you can do
the same and run any model like in Gemma
4 if you want on your on your iPhone.
If you have any question also.
>> [applause]
>> Does this support tool calling? Sorry?
Does this Yes, like so yeah, I forgot
about that. So, it support tool calling.
Um
not yet
custom not yet structured generation.
There are some package on top of MLX
Swift LM that are trying to to make this
make this working. Um
I will let you Hugging Face is doing it,
but you can easily find them online. But
MLX Swift LM, yes, it support tool
calling. So, that's really useful if you
want to do tool calling and call over
over system. And the model the model are
getting also better at tool calling.
They were not so great like a year ago.
Now it's getting much better.
I see you mentioned two things. First
was the GitHub repo. Yes. And then the
second thing was the app.
Um
So, you have the GitHub repo for
for MLX Swift LM. That's the the package
that will install in your app. And then
you need to go to a game face and
and getting
to get the weight of the model.
But for for a normal user, they can just
download the app from the app Oh, and
yes, if you want to try my app, you can
if you want to try it like right now
without having anything to install, you
can do that. And you can choose any open
source model inside that. Uh
there is a selection that that they are
not it's not any like I'm ensuring that
all the model ones correctly
on the on the iPhone because not all of
them work work well.
Thank you very much.
>> [music]